well you know they say the fact that if
something really happens or a person
really exists that's the defense of the
mediocre novelist you know but in fact
there were there were a couple of
real-life models especially the police
the there was a there was a guy used to
be robbery sergeant a 7th precinct who
then became a homicide sergeant and he
was involved in one of these cases these
sort of culture clash homicides and he
sort of walked me through it and and
coached me through at ninjas by as Moses
I sort of picked up his demeanor and his
personality for the catching detective
his partner this were talkin woman
Yolanda Bella was sort of based on his
real life partner and she was this sort
of brilliant a projects girl who was the
a-number-one interrogator in of the
universe and she did it by transforming
herself into the big sister girlfriend
mother that these these kids never had
and she could make herself tear up on
cue she could talk to them like there
was still back in the projects she'd
feel so freaked out for them and they
loved her and I told her anything she
went to know in fact she even had a guy
confess to the murder not because he did
it but because he thought it would help
her career you know and she's the only
detective I know still gets fan letters
from from prisons all around New York
State say yo you said you were going to
come visit me you know and serious I
mean to both of them are fairly
charismatic people um are the characters
in the book you know that whole world of
22 year olds you know sometimes they get
criticized that I didn't give them a
break i made them too self-centered but
I mean I think that's basically writing
about have 22 year olds perceive the
world you know and it is all about you I
have two kids I mean not that I used
them for research but my kids knew the
Lower East Side better than I did five
years ago because they knew where to go
not to get carted they knew
we're to hear music they knew what clubs
to meet their friends and they could get
into places that wouldn't even look at
me twice what they didn't know was that
they're great grandfather lived a
hundred yards from the Knitting Factory
and was being put in the back of a paddy
wagon because he just beat somebody up
for money so his mother could pay rent
and what I realized is a lot of these
kids they have they have met they have
made a full circle over five generations
that their family started out here maybe
eighteen ninety 1900 1910 and here it is
2005-2006 2007 and they're back down in
the same neighborhood when i remember
when i got i had a loft about a block or
two above houston and my grandfather was
still alive i said well you got to come
down and see this great place i have and
he wouldn't come he says what are you
mocking me i spent my whole life trying
to get out of there you know and i
couldn't explain to him no no it's
different you know he was just I mean it
was it was like telling somebody oh you
got to come back to Auschwitz they were
you know they really they really it's
really hip now you know it's a hell it
was a brutal place it was a hell of a
place the whole point of the lower east
side was to succeed because you didn't
have to live there anymore